Elle est avec nous, Tasha
Keriddin, commentatr
coprésidente de la campagne de
Jean Charest dans cette course
a la direction, et une denonono.
Tasha, bsosoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Dans votre livre, vous parzz
d'un Parti conservateur à la
croisé
entre populistes et
pragmatistes. On saura dans
moins de trois semaines qui este
à la direction. Et c't t le camp
des populistes qui semble
On ne s'attend pas que les
bulletins de vote ne sont to
remis. S'il y a 50 % des gens
qui remettent leur bul'o'o'o'o'a
voir. C'est une course sur le
terrain. Tout le monde sort,
Monsieur Charest c
entrées de faire stitir le vote.
C'est cette puissance qui va
jouer à la fin de la journée.
- Quand on regegarde les sondag,
on se rend compte qu'il n'y a
pas beaugégégégégégégégégégégégr
comme Monsieur Charest
- Dans les gens qui ne sont pas
des co
Chart t dans plusieurs sondages
auraient un meilleur score.
Mais ce n'est pas ce que je
trtete dans le livre. L'idée est
de démontrer que ces deux
courants représentent deux voies
trieieieieieieieieieieieieieieis
choses néfastes qui peuvents'ats
que le fait du conservatisme, si
on le retrouve dans son état
pur, qui est une vision de
responsabilité et de liberté,
mais en même temps de
responsabilité, de devoir à la
général, si ça est plus
expliqué... Des gens qui se sont
ralliés au populisme pourraient
se rallier à ça. On rattraperait
plus de gens de centre-droit
avec ça.
pour les conservateurs d'aller
dans cette voie qu'on croyait un
On se demandait si ça allait
arriver au Canada.
- C'est arrivé. C'est arrivé
plus tard ici qu'aux États-Unis
et dans le reste du monde.
processus. Mais la COVID n'est
pas à jamais non plus.ntntntntnt
en train de tomber, déjà qui ont
été alimenté, vont-ils trtre là
pour travailler dans une
élection, se rattacher à un
parti ou c'est juste une colère
qui s'exprime qui est usus
temporaire? Les études
démontrent que le popu
des vagues, maisisisisisisisisi0
ans pour les parties.
C'est pour çquque j'ai dit que
c'est quelque chose de plus
solide sur quoi se baser.
- Éric hahaime ici en a fait son
slogan. Pi
beaucoup de liberté. Les
camionneurs aussi. Qu'est-ce qui
attire?
- Ces rtrteurs et c'est pas
port
centaines de conservateurs en
ririvant ce livre. Il y a des
par le sentiment de liberté.
Déjà ont perdu leur liberté pour
opérer leur commerce, ils
veulent être libres à faire ses
choix. Mais pour d'autres, ça a
n'est plus simplement la
liberté, c'est la liberté de
l'effet sur nos voisins, sur
autrui. Et ce n'est pas ça qu'il
cherche. Comme aux États-Unis,
où ça a été attaché aux
extrémismes. C'est malheureux
principe conservateur.
Jeudi que le mot qui regroup
tout le monde, c'est
l'opportunité. Ce que tout le
monde cherche, ce n'est pa
n'importe quoi, c'est
l'opportunité d'acheter
maison qu'on veut, avoir le
travail qu'on veut ou unosososo.
L'opportunité et l'égalité
d'opportunité, c'est ceux à quoi
le parti doit ac
- Le message arrive un peu tard
dans cette coue.e.
- Je nsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqss
gens sont la. Déjà ont eu la
chan d de réfléchir à tout ça et
de parler au candidat.
Je pense qu'ils vont faire un
i i i i i i i i i i i i i i i i0
ptptembre, j'espère que les
élections ne vont pas tomber le
aux parties de se regrouper pour
la prochaine élection.
- Un député a déjà annoncé qu'il
ne serait pas là si Monsieur
Paul Poilièvre était élu. Vous,
qu'allez-vous faire?
- Je vais militer pour le parti
parce que c'est ce que je fais.
Je vais voir ce que le chef va
faire. Ce chef, qui que ce soi
allegro défie de garder le p
ensemble. Il doit tendrea a main
à ceux qui n'étaient pas danse e
que tous les conservateurs vont
regarder, est-ce queetette main
va être tendu et quelles seront
les efforts pour garder la
famille enselelelelelelelelelela
prochaine élection.
- Ce ne se p pas un troisième
parti comme vous l'évoquez dans
votre li
- C'est ce qu'on craint, mais on
ne devrait pas le faire. Parce
que
le vote. Présente des libéraux